the whole lot of you
all you special needs out there that's
what your mother say to us
when you don't want to get vaccinated
because it's not fda approved yet and
you will go to
starbucks never once checking to see if
the fda has approved pumpkin spice right
well if it's a starbucks it has been
approved if you
knew what it took for me to get my kid
from the front door to the car seat you
would understand that i would wear a
mask every day for the rest of my life
so apparently if we're special needs we
just get to stay home because of you
selfish you know what
a lot of you okay i actually couldn't
make sense of most of what she was
saying because because every other word
was an expletive if a food product makes
it to market in america that means that
it has gone through regulate so it
actually you don't need to check because
you know that the fda actually came out
with with this vaccine and said well
this is this is an emergency youth
authorization but not a full
authorization you'll be shocked to hear
this she doesn't know what she's talking
about